Judging by the percentages we discussed before, mental illness is pretty
common, something that every family experiences either directly or indirectly.
Because of this, mental health literacy is something that we should strive for
as a culture, given that almost half of us will experience some type of
disorder in our life. In addition, over half of the people who experience at
least one psychological disorder, will also experience a second disorder.
Having two or more mental disorders occurring at the same time, is termed
comorbidity. The new DSM-5 lists 21 major categories of disorders and over 350
distinct disorders. Now, as we mentioned at the beginning of the study, we want
to remind you that not all psychologists agree with the categories in the
DSM-5, or with the notion that there are 350 distinct disorders. And also it's
important to know that what's considered a disorder in the past, sometimes
changes over time. So the DSM isn't set in stone. For example, homosexuality
was listed as a mental disorder in the DSM. Which clearly we know no longer is
the case. Nevertheless, given the historical use of the DSM, we'll discuss some
of these categories in this lesson. Specifically, we'll discuss some of the 21
major categories of disorders, Including, Neurodevelopmental disorders,
Depressive disorders, Bipolar disorders, Anxiety disorders,
Obsessive-compulsive disorder, Post traumatic stress disorder, Dissociative
disorders, Somatic symptom disorders, Personality disorders, and finally
schizophrenia.